ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
frau bundeskanzlerin erst mal ich glaube
das war eine sehr sehr gute sehr
wichtige und sehr verantwortungsbewusste
diskussion die wir geführt haben
die war geprägt von dem tiefen
bewusstsein wie wir unser land und die
menschen weiter schützen können
eines kann man glaube ich sagen
deutschland ist bislang im vergleich zu
vielen anderen ländern besser durch
diese schlimme krise die global
stattfindet gekommen
wir können schon sagen dass wir corona
zumindest anders unter kontrolle haben
als in vielen anderen ländern der welt
warum weil die strategie die wir
entwickelt haben die richtige war
rechtzeitig frühzeitig zu handeln und
konsequent zu bleiben
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir diesen
grundlegenden weg fortsetzen
ich freue mich heute dass wir weiter
einen vorsichtigen weg beschritten haben
wir haben keine unkontrollierten exit
strategien diskutiert sondern wir setzen
weiter auf vorsicht auch vorsicht denn
wir glauben dass die größte gefahr
bestehen könnte
dass die guten zahlen das heißt guten
zahlen also die entwicklung die stabil
ist dass die einen rückschlag erleidet
wenn wir zu viel riskieren wenn wir
leichtsinnig werden und wenn wir
normalität vortäuschen dies noch nicht
geben kann solange es keinen impfstoff
solange es keine medikamente gibt
solange müssen wir einen weg an konzept
finden mit corona zu leben in form von
so viel sicherheit wie möglich aber auch
den möglichkeiten der freiheit den
menschen wieder zu geben
vor dem hintergrund haben wir heute die
unterschiedlichsten bereiche diskutiert
miteinander gewogen wir haben spielräume
entwickelt war natürlich länder
unterschiedlich betroffen sind
das süden deutschlands ist stärker
betroffen mit infektion als andere teile
von deutschlands insofern haben wir auch
rahmen definiert die unterschiedlich
ausgeschöpft werden können
beispielsweise für mein land kann ich
sagen wir werden das vorsichtiger
angehen und etwas zurückhaltend angehen
aber die möglichkeiten sind auch je nach
der infektion lage stärker zu gewichten
wichtig ist vorsicht besonnenheit ist an
der stelle wichtig als überstürztes
vorgehen was uns in einigen wochen zu
einem ergebnis führen könnte dass die
zahlen sie schlechter entwickeln und wir
dann zurück drehen müssen denn über
eines darf sich keiner täuschen
die gute entwicklung
hängt mit den maßnahmen zusammen
getroffen worden auch länder die anfangs
anders gedacht haben sind letztlich den
weg in deutschland geht nahezu
vollständig gefolgt einige später einige
unter schmerzen dass wir glaube ich
sollte mir in deutschland nicht
vergessen dass es ganz anders aussehen
könnte hätten wir falsch zu spät oder
nicht umsichtig reagiert
wir wollen uns jetzt nicht durch die
gegend asten soll derweil mit versuchen
mit weitblick und übersicht durch diese
weitere krise zu führen
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir in
schritten arbeiten und schauen wie die
schritte wirken nicht nur was die
schritte an normalität bedeuten sondern
vor allem was bedeuten die schritte auch
in der entwicklung der infektionen und
deswegen nicht alles auf einmal sondern
abgestuft zeitversetzt bestimmte
bereiche einfacher bestimmte bereiche
deutlich zurückhaltender
die philosophie muss lauten fortsetzen
das strategie erleichtern womöglich ist
das aber mit schutz versehen jede
erleichterung mit schutz versehen und
wichtig die vorsorge intensiv ausbauen
aufbauen
das ist das erste und vielleicht auch
nach wie vor die wichtigste botschaft
die distanz gebot ausgangs
beschränkungen oder kontakt span wie
immer man es kennt die bleiben erhalten
geschäfte werden leicht und schrittweise
geöffnet aber mit schutzkonzepte
schutzkonzepte heißen infektions
schützende bereiche zu machen
desinfektionen abstand zu halten
auch bestimmte 2020 auf 20 quadratmeter
eine person zu nehmen
und deswegen genau den bereich auf der
masken in den vordergrund zu rücken
für uns ist klar der staat sorgt was die
masken struktur betrifft für
medizinische masken um im pflege in
altenheimen in krankenhäusern und bei
ärzten die hochwertigen ganz besonders
auch schwierig herzustellen masken
sicherzustellen
das ist aufgabe des staates aber bei
geschäften und im privaten und im öpnv
bereich ist es wichtig dass man auch mit
einfachen community masken mit einem
entsprechenden mund und nasenschutz
entsprechend auch selbstständig erklären
kann deswegen ja bei geschäften gibt es
eine 1
leicht eröffnung wie man das wohl etwas
zeitversetzt machen aber es gibt diese
öffnung bis maximal 800 quadratmeter
auch da ist unterschiedlich wäre das
ausschöpfen
es muss eben der jeweiligen struktur
entsprechend auch verantwortet werden
ich halte es aber für richtig dass wir
diese form machen aber immer noch einmal
mit der hygiene konzept deswegen kann
man das auch nicht gleich machen war
gerade kleinere geschäfte brauchen ein
stückweit zeit um die umsetzung zu
machen auch da gilt der grundsatz
langsamer bringt mehr erfolg als
hektisch und überstürzt auch für die
wirtschaft klar ist dass gastronomie
hotel für tourismus bars diskurs
kaufhäuser shopping malls also alles das
muss sich ändern viele menschen
ansammeln nach wie vor nicht geöffnet
werden können
wir werden im nächsten wochen dann
entscheiden wie aber dass wir
zurückhaltend sind können sie daran
sehen dass wir großveranstaltungen bis
ende august bereits klar gesagt haben
das geht nicht also alles was an
bierfest man großveranstaltungen ist
werden auf keinen fall stattfinden
können denn bis dahin haben wir weder
medikamente noch im stoff und wir haben
gesehen dass der apres ski finnische
dass der karneval in heinsberg oder
stark wir bei unseren tirschenreuth das
waren ja leider plattformen in der eine
starke und auch schlimme ausbreitung
möglich gewesen deswegen da große
zurückhaltung was die
glaubensgemeinschaft mit spd
bundeskanzlers zu recht gesagt wir
schätzen dass guter glaubensfreiheit
enorm und es hat jeden geschmack es an
ostern zu sehen
der wundert es werden übrigens auch
beispielsweise wieder mehr der heilige
vater und der papst diese messe auch in
einem sehr starke beute land wie in
italien das ganze gemacht hat da wird
über konzepte nachgedacht wie wir das
vernünftig miteinander machen können zu
schulen
bei schulen da sind wir uns einig und da
bin ich sehr sehr dankbar dass wir da
keine falschen entscheidung getroffen
haben und wie ab nächster woche alles
öffnen denn auch unser lehrerverbände
den ich an der stelle ein großes
dankeschön sagen möchte die lehrerin
lehrerverbände in deutschland machen
sich wirklich gute gedanken wie wir den
schulbetrieb klug machen können auch die
kmk arbeitet bereits für uns ist wichtig
dass er für die länder ganz entscheidend
weil sie auch unterschiedliche zeit
zyklen haben mit abitur prüfungen mit
ferien zunächst mal dass man die
vorbereitung
hilft das abitur prüfungen
beispielsweise oder mittlere reife oder
quali stattfinden können das ist der
erste schritt dann erst mit einer
zeitversetzt haid das ist dann ab 11
würden wir sind bayern machen ab viertem
1 andre dann über abschlussklassen zu
reden und andere dinge die grundschule
kita bleiben vorerst allerdings versehen
mit notfallbetreuung auszuweiten
denn wenn wir bestimmte geschäfte öffnen
brauchen wir ja auch eine entsprechende
bessere betreuung da haben sich die
länder verpflichtet da ist an der stelle
zu machen und die kultusminister müssen
sich dann mit den fragen noch einmal
beschäftigen wie wir bei mehr schülern
in der schule das zu organisieren dass
abstand gehalten werden kann
welche fächer unterrichtet werden müssen
wie man auch mit versetzungen umgeht was
ganz wichtig ist denn vielen schülern
viel zeit um sozusagen in der kritischen
phase eine versetzung zu schaffen
andere wären froh wenn es dann schon zu
ende gewesen wenn das schuljahr
es müssen wir sehr klug überlegen da
brauchen wir sehr seriöse konzepte damit
die für allen ermittelt werden können
aber noch mal wichtig bei grundschulen
und kitas die bleiben vorerst die soft
ist denkbar vierte klasse also übertritt
bleiben erst einmal geschlossen
wir glauben einfach dass man auch den
kleinen kindern nicht zumuten kann
mit mundschutz und ähnlichem zu leben
oder zu arbeiten und da ist es auch sehr
schwer zu appellieren jetzt zu sagen
verhaltet euch mal entsprechend zu und
wie ich schon manche erwachsene sich
schwer tun was das thema mundschutz
betrifft geht natürlich übrigens auch
für den öpnv
ich glaube dass wir im öpnv dass wir in
bereichen auch der geschäfte die jetzt
sich weiterentwickeln in der öffnung
dass wir da er stärker dieses masken
gebot verstehen müssen
und auch da stärker daran erinnern
müssen denn all die bereiche wo man kurz
auch zusammen ist sehr nah oder abstand
schwerer zeugnis da ist eine maske da
ist ein mundschutz ein ganz einfacher
übrigens und nasenschutz ein hilfreiches
instrument bis voranzubringen
letzter punkt strategie fortsetzen
erleichterungen machen
und vorsorge versteht unser ziel ist ja
wenn es optimal lief in so einer phase
wie bei webasto zu kommen dass wir die
einzelfälle infektionsketten gut
verfolgen konnten das drama in italien
war ja dass infektionsketten nicht mehr
verfolgbar waren und damit völlig
unkontrollierte ausbreitung da war das
gelingt uns aber nur wenn der neben der
erhöhung der intensivbetten weiter und
ich glaube man kann jetzt eigentlich
sondern das deutsche gesundheitssystem
bei aller kritik die es immer geht hat
den internationalen bewährungstest im
moment gut bestanden
es kann wirklich sagen und wir gehen
eher höher sagen wir wollen eher mehr
machen
wir brauchen mehr in den städten mehr
medizinische versorgung
wir brauchen ganz wichtig mehr test
kapazitäten die müssen wir deutlich
ausweiten
bei uns beispielsweise wir testen
wirklich sehr sehr viel und wir wollen
die test kapazität noch einmal massiv
ausbauen
weil nur über tests wird die gesamte
datenlage und auch die verfolgung von
infektionsketten gewinnen können und
lasten und liest wir brauchen auch den
ausbau der gesundheitsämter bei uns wenn
es 4000 personen sein die wir zusätzlich
bilden also insgesamt 650 teams allein
in bayern die die jeweilige
rückverfolgung und auch beobachtung und
entsprechende beachtung der
infektionskette machen können fazit ich
bin im bund sehr dankbar der bund hat
heute als sehr mitgeholfen dass auch aus
unterschiedlichen positionen der länder
am ende ein gemeinschaftlicher geist
weiter herrscht es ist glaube ich ganz
wichtig also deutschland hat eine
gemeinschaftliche philosophie und auch
die debatten der letzten tage glaube ich
sind jetzt heute in ein gutes ergebnis
gemündet es verlässlichkeit
vergleichbarkeit und großen ganzen sehr
einheitlicher rahmen
in ganz deutschland gibt es gab schon
ein paar kleine unterschiede die sind
aber nicht schlimm die bleiben auch mal
eine woche hin oder her aber im großen
und ganzen sind alle länder sich mit dem
bund komplett einig in der strategie und
die strategie heißt vorsicht heißt da
wir sind noch nicht über den berg aber
wenn wir diese geduld die wir haben
weiter klug umsetzen dann glaube ich
werden wir am ende vielleicht sogar aus
dieser ganzen situation gestärkt
hervorgehen können als es viele viele
andere länder der welt schaffen können
wie das